Trump is appealing to the worst elements
in our society hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with reason TV and today we're talking
with Jerome to Chile his latest book is
the roughest riders the untold story of
the black soldiers in the
spanish-american war he's also the first
biographer of one Donald Trump he wrote
a book called Trump in 1985 and we're
talking to Jerry to Chile about insights
that he has into this man who might be
President Jerry thanks for talking to us
my pleasure your book from 1985 it
starts with a scene of teenage Donald
he's 13 or 14 at the opening of the
verrazano-narrows bridge a big arc you
know architectural engineering
achievement what happened there and what
lesson that Donald take away well Don
was present there and the architect of
the bridge was standing in the
background and introduced to the public
yet who exactly was who made the
announcement but left his name out just
talked about this great architect and so
on and maybe forgot his name or didn't
bring it up and Trump is standing there
and the lesson that he learned was that
everything I build from here on end is
going to have my name stamped on it that
was the beginning of the Donald Trump
that we know today a man who actually
makes most of his money by selling his
brand to other builders if they want to
build a hotel miami go someplace else
and put trump on it which has got some
sort of cash cash eh i guess they have
to buy the rights from this so talk a
little bit about where Donald Trump came
from I mean he's the second generation
real estate mogul in New York and you
know what was what was driving him on
his kind of ride up the the hierarchy
during the 1980s well his father was
Fred Trump who built a lot of high-rise
condos and apartments and coney island
but he was out of manhattan manhattan
was the big builders there was
zeckendorf and Helmsley if you want to
make it in New York you want to make it
in Manhattan at Lisa yeah you want to
get into Manhattan and Donald saw an
opportunity in 1975 when New York City
was basically in receivership and the
state floated these municipal assistance
corporation bonds Mac bonds to get new
york to the crisis and the old Commodore
hotel on the corner of forty-second
Street over by grand central station was
actually literally boarded up and the
Trump family the father had great pole
in New York with the Governor Hugh Carey
the mayor of the city of a beam I mean
they were big contributors to the
Madison club in Brooklyn democratic
stronghold and Trump wanted to go in
there but they got the first commercial
real estate abatements ever given to any
any realtor in New York which basically
guaranteed a profit it was like 50 years
of no taxes if he would go in there and
take over the Commodore which is it so
Donald Trump's rise in real estate her
as a kind of international mogul really
starts with you know government
assistance with with a rigged market he
later he's very fond of eminent domain
he's used that what would be eminent
domain abuse actually right in order to
build projects and in New York as well
as Atlantic City and elsewhere talk a
little bit about that does he do you see
him as a true kind of randiyan
capitalist or is he more of a crony or
or is that just not even the right way
to be thinking about no he's definitely
not a randiyan capitalist by any stretch
of the imagination he doesn't do a deal
unless somebody else is putting up the
money he's very good at losing other
people's money and preserving his own
usually he brings to the table his name
and the political clout the tax deals
and then he'll bring in a partner
whether it's Mary at or hyatt and they
put up the bulk of the money I mean he's
and then of course the same thing was
true in Atlantic City where you need
some mob ties to get in down there but
he had very little of his own money at
risk it was always other people's and
he's filed for bankruptcy with these
corporations about four times and in the
last 15 years or so knowing what you do
about
his psychology what do you think is
driving him into this you know kind of
you know totally bizarre and surprising
and yet incredibly and seemingly
unstoppably successful bid for the
Republican nomination yes I'm I'm
actually stunned that he's come as far
as he has I mean every time he shoots
his mouth off and comes out with these
basically no nothing attacks on the
system and everything else people fly to
his cause I think it's a reflection of
the general state in this country have
discussed with the establishment and I
think of it in terms of when democracies
and republic start to fail as ours is it
opens a door for demagogue to come along
as strong man and people say they want
somebody new and that new person Donald
Trump is to me a conversion of Vladimir
Putin and even have the same taste in
women you know East European hookers the
thugs they're racketeers and they could
probably sit down across the negotiating
table very well and get along because
neither one be sure who was the buffer
isn't that unfair though to to trump you
know i mean he he may have certain
accoutrements of a Russian strongman but
he's not killing people he's not
invading countries and things like that
I mean what what drives him is there
something in him that he has to do no
matter what what is he compulsive about
well he needs to get the headlines he
needs power he's got money what's left
for him he's got fame powers what's left
Trump is appealing to the worst elements
in our society should he become
president he hasn't killed anybody he's
not a Vladimir Putin yet because he
doesn't have the power but he's a
demonized every country that we do
business with including Russia and
Mexico and China and China and how are
you going to deal with these people you
know what you're going to do settle well
with China you're going to set up well
with Russia I don't know what he would
do I don't think he knows what he would
do if he gets there do you think the
Donald Trump story does it end in a
comedy or tragedy well as a comic
tragedy now it's a buffoonery at its
worst being taken seriously
by a large swath of the population what
is the likely scenario which he
self-destructs at some point I would
certainly hope that when the primaries
really heat up that he's going to start
losing a couple and find a way to drop
out by claiming victory saying you know
he could have won if he wanted to stay
in but find a way not not to do that I
think the worst scenario is that he
actually goes on and the Republicans
don't know what to do with him because
if he wins primaries how were they going
to deny him the nomination so that's the
worst case scenario for the Republican
Party and the country would be that if
he actually does get the nomination the
Democratic side is is bankrupt we're in
the stage of the Roman Empire before the
Caesars came in and 2016 may give us a
Caesar and which will kind of
precipitate the final collapse of their
other Republic that we created we don't
know yet it's still a ways off but that
would be the worst-case scenario alright
well we'll leave it there we've been
talking with Jerry to Chile he is the
author most recently of the roughest
riders the untold story of the black
soldiers in the spanish-american war and
he was the author of the very first
biography of Donald Trump which was
called Trump and published in 1985 Jerry
thanks for talking to my pleasure a lot
of fun for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you